head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts CNN reports
dozens of documents naming Jeffrey
Epstein's victims and Associates to be
made public in 2024 I chose CNN because
uh you know they they they they try to
lie about the sources we use here but
here's the story about 177 names will be
released this includes Associates
recruiters staff members uh this
includes housekeepers and it includes
victims they're saying uh according to
this judge they have uh two weeks 14
days to release these names judge
Loretta a presca the latest filing in a
case File to settle a case by Virginia
Roberts jefra she claimed Epstein abused
her and uh uh Maxwell defamed her I
believe it was settled but journalists
have filed saying that these people are
are are publicly known public figures
and therefore the all the do's they call
it in the list should be named there's
still two weeks for people who are on
the list to come forward or to go to the
court and say hey don't release my name
for this reason maybe one person ruins
the whole thing for everybody else but
who knows this is the question I posed
to X earlier and I ask you guys and
everyone listening like do you even
believe the list when it comes
out I mean it's not going to include the
names you want it to include they're
they're going to have a housek ER you're
you're going to you're going to it's
going to you know it's going to Janet
Smith and you're going to be like I
don't know I think it's it's a better
question do you believe that the list is
complete when it comes out yeah true I
think it depends on who's on it and why
because they they have the normal people
on there to make it seem more normal
they
need they they want to throw someone
under the bus mhm and I'm sure there are
high level people who are involved with
that who are like just give the people
something you know this is what happens
with big corporations when they engage
in serious Mal
some lowlevel VP will get yeah charged
and they'll be like ah we got them and I
think that was part of The Big Short
none of these people who are engaged in
this in this fraud get criminally
charged but there's like one guy that
they end up charging saying he's the one
there you got your sacrificial lamb have
a nice
day yeah this is like something where I
think you need like multiple judges that
could all have access to this so they
all they all release it the same time so
it's not like just one judge and it
could be easily contaminated and there's
been there's just been so many lies told
around this entire thing this entire
Epstein Affair that like you're right
why would you believe biss he's been
given good treatment in jail decades ago
like his roots are so deep I just I have
a hard time trusting anything and they
somehow convicted uh what how you say
your name Max convictor of sex
trafficking but like they would they
would not say hoi sex traffic to right
yep all of it's so absurd this is uh
this is our last week before we take off
for Christmas it's going to be great so
what's uh what is it today's Tuesday so
uh what is Friday the 21 no Friday's
22nd 22nd 22nd yeah Saturday's 23rd it's
going to be an awesome Christmas and I'm
hoping that as I am sitting there
relaxing wearing a a fuzzy sweater of
some sort and drinking cocoa that the
Christmas present we end up getting
maybe not on Christmas but soon will be
some accountability as it pertains to
the Epstein list yeah you know my view
is you will get cold Tim pool you will
get Cal I have a feeling but I but look
I'll tell is here if some of the names
that come out it's like a housekeeper
I'm fine like I'll take I'll take a
housekeeper if you were cleaning up for
this man and you knew what he was doing
I want to know who you are right yeah if
you saw and that's not all we want but
it's a start those like restraining
chairs he had in his bathrooms and stuff
and you're like living in that house
cleaning it up yeah for sure like who
installed those for sure for sure look
the if you get people that were on the
premises this is how investigations go
you you get someone that was there that
knows something you interrogate them or
you investigate them who do they what do
they know who who else do they know like
that's the way they that investigations
normally go whoever comes out and they
they actually name there should be now I
don't know if it actually will happen
but there should be pressure or some
some da or whatever that is trying to
find more information about it because
clearly they have been slow rolling it
and they came out and said that the
names on the list you know back when it
when they when fste first died or
whatever they they came out and said
that the names on the list they it was
too volatile to let out thank you se he
did say died in quotes and I agree I I'd
like that to be the case but I think of
things like when someone is running for
politics and they all a sudden he's on
the or she's on the we website and then
people are like well the W puts them on
there to discredit them or they're on
the we website and that discredits them
you know yeah so it's like a constant
back and forth of these scops as well
like who who's going to be on it and
maybe there's like a who's going to
benefit from that person being on it is
what I'm worried about you don't know I
just keep it in mind when it comes to
the the W stuff I I kind of just always
get the impression that only in the past
year two years have kind of has it
become broadly known throughout the the
I guess the dissident community that the
WF is actually really really bad it was
there was a time where like talking
about Davos and talking about the the
people that get together at Davos and
and the WF and and the Council on
Foreign Relations and stuff is if you
brought any of those things up in any
type of critical context then you were a
crazy person you know you were you was
that was Alex Jones stuff well well not
just him Bill Burr before he was
neutered used to talk about those
meetings all the time on Conan O'Brien
show yeah and so that and that's the
thing it's like if you're critical of it
you're a crazy person but if you were
listening to spev brzinsky talking to Ma
and Joe about it on MSNBC at 8:30 in the
morning
if you're talking about them and and you
are praising them then obviously this is
just normal Nos and and organizations
and stuff but if you're critical well
then you're Alex Jones yeah so I mean
obviously it's it's it's the Paradigm of
like it's it's not happening and you're
crazy but if it is it's a good thing
that it's actually Happ exactly oh
that's so true frustrating as hell it's
terrifying well I hope the list comes
out and we can accountability would be
great cuz accountability seems
completely rare these days it's just
we're so hyper politicized it's like
it's hard for me to even see
accountability on the horizon
accountability I don't I don't believe
in accountability anymore it's just the
use of political persecution to to sty
your opponents you know again and
generally that's you know conservatives
you know or or people that are outside
of the the norm of progressive
sensibilities but I mean again we we
talked about it a little bit you know
you look at at Santos and granted he
clowned on all of Congress and he
clowned on basically his entire District
cuz they did elect him you know so I
mean he he did was it poo that called
him gay Joker this morning I don't I
don't know but incredible go look at
Poo's Twitter page don't disrespect
Santos no he I think he meant it in a
good way because it was a hilarious
interview Santos treated Congress the
way that Congress deserves to be treated
that's Absolut and that's that's why I'm
I'm
surpris you such a supporter he treated
them exactly how they deserve mhm and
the crazy thing is the guy got no due
process none I got no D process and
you're right his district did elect him
and he's New York has their primaries I
think like in the early spring summer so
he was way less he was like eight months
out from getting probably quite a few
hard primary challenges but then they
came in and said no this guy's guilty we
got to throw him out right now like why
didn't they just let the process
actually work I don't know why
Republicans have to rush in
automatically say no no no we'll take
care of this like we'll kick this bum
out of here meanwhile Menendez has got
gold bars from the government of Egypt
and he's are the Democrats going to kick
him off the Foreign Affairs committe
like no way no way unbelievable 2024 is
going to be fun it's going to be wild I
don't know what else to say I mean it's
we're where I've been saying before I
can't see you know normally when
something happens I have like several
ideas of what I think it might lead to
and you know a lot I get it wrong A lot
of times sometimes I get it right I mean
with like Colorado kicking Trump off off
the ballot I think it's I'm in the
ballpark you know what I mean yeah what
I I I I I had Media Matters roasting me
well I say roasting they claimed that I
likely had four knowledge of January 6th
because in September of 2020 I said
these oathkeepers and proud boys and
3centers they're going to storm to DC in
November and just like storm the White
House or something and they were like he
must have known about January 6 I was
like first of all it happened in January
not November second of all they didn't
go to the White House they went to the
capital building and more importantly
it's cuz I read the news news it wasn't
a real prediction if I had any influence
on the January Sixers I would have told
him to go to all the people that the
houses of the people that that live work
at Media Matters no I don't I take that
back I I think the problem he not going
the door and have a polite conversation
in any legal context but my point is
it's starting to come in view with the
removal of trump in Colorado it's
starting to starting I'm starting to you
know get an idea of things that could
happen from this you end up with Trump
uh uh unable he not that he'll be
removed from every state in the primary
but just enough to that he can't win
yeah you end up with Ronda santz as the
nominee The Establishment says guys look
you know we we we're not happy with this
but we we we can't let Joe Biden win so
everybody go out there and vote for Dan
santis Trump's poor is goingon to say
screw off yeah exactly I've heard you
say a bunch like it's hard and it's I
agree it's hard to Envision this future
right because like if you read all the
news you can you have a sense of the
pattern that happens and I've been
thinking you know like we might have a
normaly bias for all all of these past
years until covid then it turned into
absurdity and now it's like you have to
have an absurdity bias but it's
impossible to guess absurdity so
everything's just constantly yeah it's
the new normaly is the absurdity so and
it's almost ties into uh elon's quote
about the most likely outcome is the
most entertaining one except it's for
politics it's the most like chaotic and
depraved one you know and it's hard to
to gauge that because it's just we're so
far gone and all the Democrats care
about is power I mean they they've
proven that they will basically burn the
entire country down and so what's the
next level after that what's the next
level from 2020 World War 3 it's pretty
I mean it's incredibly frightening yeah
will they get us into World War II I
mean Biden's last address the nation he
said we all have to unify because you
know we potentially could be at War
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net